let's look at the the case I the the
actual case that uh Georgia has laid out
against Trump
um this is there's 41 counts there's 19
uh defendants named uh including Trump
and many of his lawyers Rudy Giuliani
uh you mentioned John Eastman
um act one that they zero in on here is
on the 4th of November which would be
election night 2020 When Donald Trump
gave a speech where they say he falsely
declared Victory and falsely claimed
voter fraud we have a clip from that
speech Let's Take a look at that clip
and then talk about it in the context of
this case
we won states that we weren't expected
to win Florida we didn't win it we won
it by a lot
and
it's also clear that we have won Georgia
we're up by
2.5 percent or 117
000 votes with only seven percent left
they're never going to catch us they
can't catch us
but most importantly we're winning
Pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud
on the American public this is an
embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election frankly we did win this
election
[Applause]
so I should also note that the the
um the Georgia case the prosecutors
allege that the speech was actually
drafted four days or some version of it
was drafted four days before the
election
um I'll be interested to see if they
present evidence of that but how might
that speech really particularly if
there's evidence that it was drafted in
advance implicate begin to implicate
Trump in criminal conspiracy
so what I would say is no one including
the prosecutors in the Georgia case
claims that merely giving that speech is
illegal this is something that is
misleading and some of the criticism
that is offered of the indictment that
when you have the listing of the acts
the the listing of Acts is not a listing
of things that the prosecutors say are
by themselves illegal rather that speech
which included a number of false claims
that we can talk about uh is just part
of the evidence indicating that Trump
had a broader scheme to overturn the
election result after he lost it and
indeed when did he began to lay down
even before the election that's why it's
important it was drafted ahead of time
because it's clear that he was gonna
claim fraud regardless of how and by how
much he lost uh and you know there's
evidence of that but merely saying I was
the victim of fraud would not have led
to this indictment rather the statements
about being a victim of fraud false
statements uh were uh part of a scheme
that involved things that are actually
were illegal which is uh trying to
replace the real electors with false
lecturers pressuring State officials
into falsifying to vote counts as in the
famous uh call with the uh with the
secretary of state of Georgia where he
said well find me 11 780 votes which is
happening the exact number of votes that
he was uh that he needed to overcome
Biden's lead uh in Georgia uh so uh this
is similar to if I merely say you know
Bob is a scumbag and he deserves to die
that itself is perfectly legal uh at
least it's not a criminal evaluation you
know setting aside possible claims of
libel or slander here by if I then
proceed uh to tell my flunkies you know
go out and whack Bob uh than the
previous statement where I say to Bob
deserves to die could be brought as
evidence against me in court evidence of
the motive uh and plan that I had to you
know to have Bob killed and the same
thing applies to uh Trump's statements
alleging fraud and also to Trump's plans
that were clearly weighed down even
before the election to allege fraud uh
in in any situation where he might lose
it's worth going for a moment if we have
time on what was false about Trump's
statement uh and that is uh but but we
could do it out or a few bites and move
on no lay it out for us I think that
yeah so uh so it is true that in some of
the states to Trump ended up losing on
Election night he was still leading in
the account but that was because of the
so-called blue shift uh where because
Trump for many months before Radio
Action had claimed that absentee voting
or Mayo in voting uh was fraudulent or
suspicious many Republicans believe what
he said and so Republicans
disproportionately voted on Election Day
whereas Democrats as a result
disproportionately voted by mail into
many states which permit this and
therefore in States like Pennsylvania
and some others which first counted the
in-person vote and only waiter counted
the mail vote initially uh Republicans
started out with a big lead but as these
other votes which were
disproportionately Democratic were
counted and there's nothing wrong with
counting them indeed it would be illegal
if they had not been counted and unfair
as well uh then uh what initially
started out as a a lead for the Republic
for for Trump turned into a lead for
Biden and many experts predicted ahead
of time that this is what would happen
given the hesitancy of many Republicans
to uh do mail-in voting uh which was a
new thing in the 2020 election before
2020 Act actually mail in an absentee
voting in many states was actually
somewhat disproportionate to a
republican but Trump ironically himself
was responsible for the seat for the
trend which led to the perception that
you know he had a big lead which would
somehow you know undermine uh and uh
really within hours uh of that statement
it became very clear uh that in in that
in these states uh the eventual vote
count would show uh that Trump had
pretty decisively lost he ultimately
lost Pennsylvania but I think something
like a high close to 80 or 100 000 votes
uh and he watched these other states uh
these swing states by many thousands of
votes uh as well uh and uh so clear uh
also to be clear you know to the extent
that there were any irregularities with
the ballots and the mail-in balloting
the Trump team did challenge this stuff
and I assume we are all in agreement
here that that's a totally legitimate
route yesterday
before right Trump and his supporters
filed over 60 lawsuits uh challenging
the results in various states that
itself is perfectly legal do I think it
was somewhat abusive in a case where the
overwhelming evidence was that there was
no chance that the results would be
overturned but he certainly had a legal
right to do that and that wasn't a crime
uh and it's worth noting that Trump lost
all but one of those cases and the one
he went in Pennsylvania did not come
close to overturning the uh large margin
that Biden had in that state and it's
important and this is relevant to the
criminal ask of the case that he
continued his fake electorate scheme and
other efforts to overturn the election
even after he lost all those cases uh
and even after it became clear for
nueado's cases developed uh that he and
his supporters had no real evidence of
fraud on anything like the scale
necessary to change the result
correct hold on get me uh correct me if
I'm wrong here but is it also correct
that some of the judges overseeing and
issuing you know rulings on those
lawsuits were in fact also Trump
appointed yes absolutely and indeed one
of the most eloquent and Powerful
opinions uh on this issue uh was written
by a third circuit Trump uh appointee uh
who you know he had nominated for that
position uh and it's worth noting that
in some of these State cases that were
brought in state courts uh many of those
cases were also decided uh by
Conservative Republican judges uh
obviously State judge is not federal
ones and uh Conservative Republican
election officials in a number of these
states like Georgia also certified the
results Brad raffensberger the Georgia
Secretary of State uh whom Trump tried
to pressure in that famous or notorious
call he is a Conservative Republican he
would have been very happy to see Trump
win the state of Georgia but he knew
that simply wasn't case given the margin
of over 11 000 votes and given the whack
of evidence of fraud or other problems
and anything like the scale that would
have been necessary to overturn that
margin so it's not the case that only
wibrow judges heard these cases or only
liberal Democratic officials were
involved in certifying the results
thanks for listening to our conversation
with Ilya soman on the Trump indictment
for more Clips go here for full
conversation go here